[Applaudissements]
je prends une première décision
alors vous avez vu j'ai pas mis des
baskets trop j'ai voulu casser un petit
peu le
son pas mal tous les deux
ah ouais je peux les relancer
un paddle c'est quoi comme photo une
photo de toi
mais oui mais je commence je commence au
début on commence on est nul ou quand
vous avez commencé vous étiez pas
de Casa panel absolument c'est qui est
le mieux classé du club
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être vous
plein d'autres
et puis d'ailleurs c'est les gens là-bas
c'est assez troublant puisqu'on on joue
devant votre portrait donc c'est-à-dire
que mon patron me tue toute la journée
quoi un portrait de moi sur un coin
je suis bleu cassé du club mais c'est
pas mal comme truc j'aime bien
parce que après plein plein de membres
de l'équipe qui sont mises
à
distance tu fais le tournoi demain
je sais même pas faire un revers vous
croyez que j'ai commencé à faire
vous étiez là-bas oui vous étiez là-bas
je te de Cyril numéro 1
non non non
utilisez votre talent pour la pédagogie
vous voulez pas former vos prochains
YouTube j'ai envie que les gens soient
mauvais
alors c'est John le prof mais c'est mon
prof c'est bien parce qu'il me raconte
beaucoup de dossiers sur vous du coup je
suis l'unique je peux dire tous les
dossiers alors je sais pas si je peux
raconter mais je vais le raconter quand
même quitte à recevoir un recommandé dès
demain
vous avez fait un tournoi je crois avec
votre fils et donc vous jouiez avec donc
un papa et son fils également oui sachez
que normalement il y a une morale dans
le paddle c'est ce qu'on m'a expliqué
quand voilà un papa joue avec son fils
le truc c'est voilà de jouer tranquillou
bidou quoi tout va bien on kiffe c'est
le jeu on a gagné le tournoi oui mais
pourquoi vous avez gagné le tournoi
parce que Cyril n'a aucune pitié
il a envoyé des balles de 150 km de 8
ans
et vous savez quel était la réponse de
Cyril mais je m'en fous
[Rires]
là
on a gagné le tournoi moi j'allais dire
mon fils on va racheter on va chercher
la coupe on a été chercher la coupe on
vit c'est très bien
ce qui paraît très fort
[Musique]
alors on en a parlé toutes les équipes
moi et mon fils outre toi et un membre
de la production d'accord c'est 50
balles de 7
mais vous gagnez voilà mais normalement
c'est au patron de payer ses employés
pas aux employés de payer son patron ça
n'a rien à voir c'est un pari s'il vous
plaît contre moi et mon fils vous le
prenez 50
on fait ça
je suis je peux te la demande je peux me
libérer ramène-toi avant c'est fait par
contre oui j'ai installé tu as vu dans
le club j'ai installé un distributeur de
billets
donc n'hésite pas tout le monde
on commence avec vous Cyril parce que
alors lundi 15 je sais tout je vois tous
regarde ce qui se passe pendant les pubs
pendant les magnétos évidemment et donc
Cyril vous êtes toujours autant
intéressé par vos chroniqueurs année
après année et parfois bah vous mettez
des des vents de force 7000 sur le
plateau c'est le je m'en bats les de la
semaine tu as pris 600 600 le jeu
m'emballec de la semaine
il y en a toujours eu des des
éroglisseurs il y en a toujours mais
celui-ci il est électrique et il fait
moins de bruit qu'un aspirateur donc ça
c'est révolution merci
intéressant parce que je crois non mais
vous êtes hyper intéressant d'ailleurs
en général dans la vie de tous les jours
on essaye vous êtes très élégant en plus
sympa cette pochette là comme ça avec ça
bah bravo on continue on continue avec
le muscle de la semaine à votre avis
quel est le chroniqueur qui gratte au
plus de râteliers possible et
imaginables
chez vous des apparences alors c'est un
autre qui a été à TF1 et qui doit plus
lui rester grand chose de ces années
là-bas
le Mushkin de la semaine
et de toute façon
[Applaudissements]
à mon extrait préféré de la semaine
Cyril attends attends c'est mon extrait
préféré non non non
vous êtes dedans oui vous êtes dedans
mais vous êtes partout parce que vous
présentez les missions
oui alors ce qu'il faut avec vous Cyril
c'est que que vous receviez le préfet de
police ou Afida Turner vous êtes le même
par contre les invités eux changent et
quand
ils sont se demandent mais qu'est-ce que
je fous ici c'est le pourquoi je suis là
de la semaine
dis moi le pourquoi je suis là de la
semaine
ça faisait longtemps ça faisait
longtemps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'utiliser sa langue pour articuler
Benjamin Castaldi répond aux abonnés
absents par contre quand il s'agit
d'utiliser sa langue pour critiquer les
gens du PAF
là c'est la langue de la semaine
de la semaine
et oui donc cette semaine on recevait
gregottin pour sa nouvelle émission sur
mycanal et en train
îné se faire
taclercs
[Applaudissements]
on ne sait pas ce qu'on veut dans la vie
elle dit quoi madame pipi
on va parler de Secret Story dans un
instant ça va pas revenir aussi et qui
va venir Cindy Lopez
et surtout la meilleure candidate qu'on
ait jamais eu je pense qu'il y a eu un
bail entre vous deux
34 minutes encore avec marié comment ça
va
pas être intéressant
vous là-bas pourquoi tu as toujours pas
vous faire pisser dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le blanc à côté c'est pas grave
ça sera toujours attention
je suis désolé
on fait pas la séquence
alors c'est pas vraiment mais ça vaut le
coup quand même j'ai une question très
franche à vous poser est-ce que vous
payez vos chroniqueurs à mater des cubes
pendant que vous pour la goutte des
matins
regardez vous allez devoir prendre des
sanctions c'est pas casser
le Charo de la semaine
quel coup de gym vraiment bravo à vous
voilà je dis moi quand des mecs font
parler d'eux et qui font ils sont
intelligents et qui font des beaucoup je
leur dis bravo
un contenu attendu passé attendu donc
c'était parmi les les personnes
auxquelles l'ont pas avoir dans Playboy
excuse-moi tu fais une émission tu es
booking toi
je m'instruis et tu décroches pourquoi
toi
on adore
le téléphone
on passe au délicat de la semaine et
c'est vous aussi
des cadeaux de la part de très gentils
et des spectateurs qui viennent et qui
vous offre des cadeaux c'est super sympa
une chose est sûre vous savez les
remercier un bâtard
le délicat de la semaine
qui c'est qui m'a offert le la statue ah
et c'est fort merci les frérots
franchement je l'ai mis là elle est
incroyable j'ai pas vu encore le zoom
mais la statue il me ramenait aussi la
statue elle est incroyable elle est chez
mise dans mon cul
excusez-moi
et merci à eux vraiment beaucoup de
cadeaux
[Rires]
on a pas compris la semaine
ça peut ça peut ça peut vous surprendre
parce que vous dites quelque chose de
très vrai Cyril que les gens parfois ils
sont normaux et quand ils viennent dans
l'émission ils repartent et ils sont
complètement bizarres et bien c'est vrai
que même en bibliothécaire portrait et
Béatrice non c'est pas Béatrice je vous
jure que la séquence est sans trucage je
vous demande de regarder la tête c'est
en temps réel c'est magnifique c'est le
on n'a pas compris la semaine
le on n'a pas compris de la semaine
un va dire la même chose nous n'avancer
la Chine a souffert il y a un an
[Musique]
c'est très long
tu peux encore toi
[Rires]
la punchline de la semaine
il n'y a rien de mieux que de se sentir
en vie pour la première fois
et le jour le plus triste de ta vie
quand je suis pris un doigt
plus de ma vie c'est quand j'ai compris
que je ne connaîtrais jamais le vrai
amour
décidément
[Applaudissements]
mardi qui nous a beaucoup intrigué on a
voulu en savoir plus on regarde d'abord
la séquence dans TPMP
voilà qu'on a ramené chez nous voilà et
on vous devez vous en donner finalement
on a décidé que non
[Musique]
et oui
vous n'avez pas voulu donner les gâteaux
au Chronicles alors on sait pas si parce
que c'était Pessac qui approché vous
avez pas le droit de manger de gâteau en
ce moment ou si vous êtes vraiment un
énorme crevard et bien je crois que je
vais devoir révéler votre vrai facette
hôtel spectateur vous êtes un crevard et
c'est le crevard de la semaine
les crevards de la semaine
sans rigoler c'est bon moi aussi j'ai
envie de goûter maintenant vous avez pas
un couteau
la prochaine pub mais laisse-les moi à
côté de moi ils sont beaux
frère je suis désolé ça donne envie
je te jure je vais me prendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je les ai pas vu ces gâteaux c'est pas
elle qui les a pris d'ailleurs ah bah
c'est peut-être je vais enquêter il y
avait deux gâteaux
j'ai trouvé ni l'un ni l'autre mais
normalement ils étaient pour deux
cartouches les chroniqueurs normalement
à mon avis
c'est incroyable merci à la semaine
prochaine
[Applaudissements]